Now that we have in
our hands the PMF
of the random variable N tau,
which is the number of arrivals
during an interval
of length tau,
we can go ahead and
try to calculate
the mean and variance
of this quantity.
Regarding the mean, we could
use just the definition
of the expected value
and then carry out
of this calculation,
which is not too hard.
And in the end, we would obtain
an answer equal to lambda times
tau.
This is indeed the correct
formula for the expected value.
But let us understand
why this formula should
be true without doing
any calculation.
Remember that the random
variable, the number
of arrivals in the
Poisson process,
is well approximated by a
binomial random variable
with those particular
parameters n and p in the limit
when delta goes to zero.
And this works through a
discretization argument.
Therefore, the
expected value of N tau
should be approximately equal
to the expected value of that we
get from the Bernoulli
processes, that is the expected
value of the binomial
random variable.
And the expected value of
a binomial random variable
is n times p.
And n times p evaluates
approximately to lambda times
tau.
The second equality here is
approximate because we're
neglecting this order
of delta squared term.
Now, these approximations
are increasingly
exact as we let delta go to 0.
And when we take the
limit as delta goes to 0,
we see that the expected value
of the number of arrivals
in the Poisson process will
be equal to lambda tau.
For the variance, we can
follow a similar argument.
First do a binomial
approximation
and use the formula
for the variance
of a binomial random variable.
And then, when delta is
small, this number p is small.
And it's negligible
compared to 1.
n times p is approximately
lambda [tau].
And so we obtain this expression
This expression here
is the correct one.
If we were to use the formal
definition of the variance
and carry out the
calculations using the PMF,
this is what we would
obtain, except that it
would be somewhat tedious.
The formulas that
we have derived,
at least the first
one, is quite intuitive
and has a natural form.
The expected number of arrivals
is proportional to tau.
If we double the length of the
time interval for interest,
we expect to see twice
as many arrivals.
This formula also reinforces
the interpretation of lambda
as an arrival rate.
Since lambda is the expected
number of arrivals divided
by the length of
time, it is, really,
the expected number of
arrivals per unit time.
So it's natural to call
lambda the arrival rate,
or the intensity of
the arrival process.
Finally, regarding the
variance, it is a curious fact
that the variance
turns out to be
exactly the same as
the expected value.
And this is a special
property of the Poisson PMF.